pour la sixième année consécutive la
ville de mort pas mis en place le mot
repas estival un événement pour divertir
les plus jeunes pendant les vacances
situé dans l'école élémentaire des
baissière maurepas estivale propose de
nombreuses attractions
le concept du maurepas stival c'est
d'accueillir tout le public de la ville
de maurepas pour proposer des animations
estivales c'est surtout pour les gens
qui n'ont pas la chance de pouvoir
partir en vacances
au programme beach volley tennis de
table baby foot tir à l'arc mais aussi
plage aménagée et transats des
animations tout public
on propose également aussi
le mardi et le jeudi à partir de la
semaine prochaine du tir au laser
on va proposer une animation curling on
à l'association pétanque y est présente
tout le matos de tout le long de
l'événement et qui va proposer de
l'animation de l'année initiation à la
pétanque
on va essayer d'avoir également
l'association alto pour faire ni 6
heures initiation aux sports de combat
pour lutter contre la chaleur estivale
plusieurs attractions jeux d'eau ont été
mises en place c'est vraiment cool
tous les animateurs sont vraiment
gentils on vient toutes les après midi
donc on est vraiment bien ici on vient
tous les jours du tout bas c'est un peu
la même chose mais on se livre toujours
du coup c'est le principal maurepas
estivale est ouvert chaque jour de 11
heures 30 jusqu'à 19 heures 30 un
concert de clôture est prévue le 26 août